[Musique]
la 21e édition du challenge des
créateurs a été lancée ce mardi 2
octobre au village corail une matinée
dédiée au speed casting où les 96
candidats ou un tour de rôle présenter
leur projet de création d'entreprise
devant le jury les a eu huit minutes
chacun j'ai une entreprise d'artisanal
en fait de création de bijoux pour homme
et femme et mes matières premières sont
essentiellement le cuir et d après
argentée avec un plaquage argent 10
microns alors ça pourrait m'aider par
exemple à pouvoir faire un salon
professionnel sur paris ça pourrait
m'aider aussi à développer ma notoriété
au niveau de l'île développer encore
plus mon activité au niveau de la
renommée et surtout aussi beaucoup des
changes avec d'autres entrepreneurs où
il ya énormément de richesse dans la
diversité des danses valeurs qui étaient
ici donc j'ai présenté un petit pupitre
en tamarins pliable de création qui
s'appelle pupitre basilou et qui destiné
aux enfants de 2 à 9 ans et une taille
plus grande de 9 ans adultes bâle-ville
gagné le prix ça serait ça ça donne un
petit coup de pouce à l'activité
artisanale qui est compliqué quand même
dans les bois mais sedan bois massif
puis du coup j'ai pris un atelier à
l'étang salé dans la zone des salles du
coup voilà j'aurai besoin d'acheter des
machines pour évoluer progresser
et embaucher et
on dira l'activité basilou des projets
innovants et performants qui ont rendu
la tâche difficile au jury pour les
départager
il y avait de beaux projets 96 candidats
qui ont présenté des projets devant le
jury on les discussions ont été âpres
mais le jury a été unanime sur le nom
des 14 lauréats donc quatorze lauréats
heureux et je dirais ils ce sont les
lauréats
mais les 96 candidats ont eu quand même
ce plaisir de pouvoir présenter leur
projet et ça servira peut-être pour
peaufiner certains points et présenter
d'autres projets dans l'avenir le
challenge des créateurs en concours qui
démontre que la création d'entreprise
peut être un outil d'insertion pérenne
est ce que le concours et la remporter
bien sûr pour les les lauréats 7000
euros en numéraire 1500 repos les
finalistes d or de conseil avec des
experts comptables des adhésions au
centre de gestion agréé du coaching de
la cgss et surtout ce que ca veut
ramener donc c'est validation de leur
projet et une valorisation en terme
d'image au travers ce concours et les
moyens médias mis en place par le
département et ses partenaires 14
finalistes pour cette pris la décision
finale sera donnée à l'issue d'un jury
institutionnelle au mois de novembre au
sein du conseil départemental
[Musique]